he was he was great fun to be around I
was fortunate to to interview him three
times and uh he was he was just fun and
I mean you know you see him winning the
World Cup I mean people talk about the
greatest player of all time and Messi's
performance in the in the recent World
Cup final and Maradona in in 86 but Pele
has to be the greatest player of all
time the greatest footballer of all time
because of the three World Cups because
of the 77 goals for Brazil because of
what he achieved obviously with with one
Club sadly he didn't come to to Europe
but also Pele was so much more than the
greatest player and the greatest team I
mean he stood out in that fantastic 1970
team rivolina and all those great
players set up that wonderful final goal
for for Carlos Alberto but he was so
much more than that he was a very
sporting individual I mean some of the
greatest moments of his career is when
he didn't actually score you know the
one around on the CZ Slovakian the
goalkeeper then when Gordon Banks made
that incredible save the saving the
century somehow clawing
um pele's downward header Over the Bar
in in 1970 and at the end of that game
there was respect there was friendship
there was kinship and when they called
the banks passed away in 2019 Pele
issued a just a very eloquent very
emotional very respectful tribute on
Facebook to Gordon Banks his friend as
he calls him and that famous picture
you're showing now of of him and the
great Bobby Moore swapping shirts
Pele was more than a football he was
about he wasn't just a competitor for
people like Moore and Banks he would he
was he was a friend because of his smile
because of his personality but obviously
because of his genius as a player and
maybe that's a quality that slightly
slipped out of the game one of the
reasons why people are mourning Pele so
deeply was because he was a sporting
individual whatever he went in the world
he was revered for his fulfilling
achievements but also what he did off
the pitch you know his foundation the
work he did with with the disadvantaged
kids he worked also helped he's an
ambassador for Great Ormond Street
hospital he echoed those roles all
around the world it wasn't simply about
you know the award ceremony or you know
the athletic overhead goals the amount
of good that he did to this world so for
me he's not simply the greatest
footballer of all time but he's one of
the greatest individuals that this
planet has ever seen
quite an Accolade there and on the World
Cups Henry you mentioned there that I
mean that 1970 World Cup those of us
that were around that uh Brazilian team
storming everything that came before
them it in a way it's almost inevitable
and an Accolade that that 1970 defined
as one of the greatest World Cups of all
time that uh he's passed away this year
in also one of the greatest World Cups
different times at one of the greatest
World Cups we've ever ever seen in
footballing terms well I think the two
greatest World Cups of all times in 1917
and 1982 but that 1917 tournament that
you mentioned I mean he was fantastic
and you you think about the final when
they dominated that Italian team that
was a fabulous Italian team you know it
wasn't just a whole bunch of journeyman
who Brazil bulldozer they were really
good team full of stars and he would
just he was the star in the galaxy of
that game but also what that showed in
that game what a team player he was I
mean one of the greatest team goals of
all times Brazil's fourth came when he
just rolled the ball into Carlos
Alberto's path he knew where his
teammate was storming up from right back
was going to be so it was that Vision it
was that selflessness that defined Pele
as well as all the you know the agility
and and the goals we saw you know some
of your footage the 1958 World Cup
juggling the ball over the defender and
and shooting but also in that World Cup
as well as Welsh fans will tell you
where Jack Kelsey the Welsh goalkeeper
was on the floor he made a save and uh
Paley accidentally tripped over him Pele
turned around apologized and helped him
to his feet that was what I will
remember about Pele the sportsmanship as
well as the great sporting ability
and tell us about you mentioned uh when
we first started chatting Henry are you
lucky enough to interview him three
times I mean we genuinely what was he
like in terms of his wit and
intelligence as well he was great fun he
could draw a crowd just as he could at
Americano whether he played around the
world Azteca he could draw a crowd I
mean even he came over in 2012 for the
London Olympics because he wanted to
support Neymar who's put out a very
eloquent poignant tribute to the great
man tonight and he was there because he
wanted to see Brazil win the uh the
Olympics they didn't manage it but he
turned up at an event at the the VNA the
Victorian Albert Museum and there he was
with Catherine Granger the Great British
horse woman at just the two of them
walking past all these sort of works of
art and Pele was just fun and he just
drew a crowd there were thousands of
people there wanting to listen to them
and and there was a Scott present he
shouted over to Pele have Scotland got a
chance of qualifying
um for the World Cup in 2014 and Pele
ever the Diplomat and ever the you know
human just a lovely guy said of course
we can all dream keep fighting keep
playing you can do it and that was Pele
it was the warmth he was in every man
but also he was a sporting God
and in terms of sporting gods that
transcended their Sport and became
Global figures how does he compare to
another great Sportsman of that era to
obviously compared to Muhammad Ali I
think Muhammad Ali in the cold light of
day and obviously everyone was very
emotional tonight and will be because of
pele's passing I think Muhammad Ali will
still Eclipse Pele because of because of
what he did in the Civil Rights because
of he you know he stood up for you know
he stood up for huge values for huge
principles in such difficult
circumstances Muhammad Ali was Brave in
the ring and brave out of the ring as
well Pele was as well but I still think
and he would he you know only he would
still hear the great man I mean he
always said it about ali my friends and
you know what a great individual as well
as a great Sportsman Ali was
but what about Pele and Pele and
politics of course some he he grew up in
difficult times in in Brazil during in
part military dictatorship
there was a Netflix documentary quite a
revealing one which came out a year or
so ago in which Pele was asked about
that and whether he could have stood up
to the military dictatorship at the time
and a particularly poisonous leader and
they were allegations surrounding him of
of torture and Pele de Pele know about
the the rumors and you know it's it's
difficult to know the sort of situation
that Pele was in at the time Santos were
obviously traveling around abroad a lot
so he wouldn't necessarily have known
completely what was going on but I think
Pele was probably slightly conflicted
about that and when you actually see
what Pele did for the people who lived
in such desperate circumstances in
Brazil and they did so much for that
country as well as for the world as well
as also clearly for football